it's great to welcome to the program
today dr. heidi toric who's an assistant
professor of international history at
the University of British Columbia and a
non-resident fellow at the German
Marshall Fund of the United States as
well as the Canadian Global Affairs
Institute great to talk to you today
appreciate your time thanks for having
me so let's talk a little bit maybe just
to establish some of the terms we're
going to be using when we talk about
public opinion and published opinion and
should be thinking about those two
concepts and how they differ what what
are we talking about published opinion
in public opinion so this is one of the
really basic distinctions that I make in
the book that I've just published is so
often political or economic elites think
that what's published in a newspaper or
today what's said on TV is public
opinion what everybody thinks and what I
would say instead is that's actually
published opinion which is what a
certain set of journalists and other
people have produced public opinion by
contrast is sort of aggregate of all the
things that people think in a population
and we have to be careful not to think
that the American public has one public
opinion so part of what I talk about is
how this often gets misunderstood and
leaders actually think that something is
public opinion that is actually
published opinion it seems that this is
a distinction that goes back I mean I
guess maybe to telegraphy right look in
the sense that there was a point at
which you as an individual existing in
the world were hearing about what people
believed from those people it really
depended on the conversations that you
were having with the so-called public
and at a certain point it became
possible to put some other sort of
opinion in the hands of those who have
access to the means of communication and
communicate more quickly than an
individual might be able to with someone
else is that sort of the origins of when
public and published opinion started to
separate extent I mean newspapers as a
genre so printed forms of news they
begin much earlier so really in the 16th
century but they don't become very
dominant until the 19th century so it's
really with industrialization that we
see the rise of the mass
urban newspaper and those are moments
that are very tied to things like
telegraphy where you can send news
across the Atlantic so much faster and
there are particular newspapers or
especially news agencies firms that
emerge that are basically just doing the
job of collecting news from around the
world and sending it through telegraphy
for other newspapers to print so a lot
of what I've written about is the power
of these news agencies so some of them
still exist today like Reuters or The
Associated Press and they really emerge
in the mid 19th century about the same
time as telegraphy and they become
really important bottlenecks of global
news there are very few newspapers that
have foreign correspondents or anything
else but most of the people who were
reading newspapers didn't really know
what news agencies were so you start to
see sort of industrial division of labor
where just a few companies are really
controlling the source of national and
international news that the vast
majority of people who are buying these
papers will read yeah I guess that's
that's a good point so I guess what I
was not in thinking of newspapers as
predating telegraphy the distribution of
those newspapers was still happening
much more slowly it depended on someone
bringing the newspaper and but you're
absolutely right that that does of
course predate telegraphy to go to the
early 20th century and the use of some
of these mass communication methods
published opinion to use published
opinion to influence public opinion
maybe in Germany we could even talk
about what are some of the important
sort of data points or milestones in the
way that this was used to government's
advantage yeah so so this really changes
quite substantially over the late 19th
and first half of the 20th century so at
first there are lots of newspapers but
it takes until even the 1890s when
scholars start to say hang on a moment
we should know how many newspapers there
are and how many people are reading them
and whether this intersects with voting
patterns at all so it begins really with
just things like press clippings so
you'll see you if you go into archives
and this is true in Germany but also in
other countries just collections of
press clippings about certain themes and
that gets taken as a kind of proxy for
public opinion so we've seen what the
conservative newspaper says and what the
liberal newspaper says and the more
Marxist newspaper and that's taken to
just represent public opinion so that is
that government elites try to intervene
in what newspapers are publishing
thinking that will then influence public
opinion and what we see then after World
War one particularly is the growth of
much more interest in more vigorous
studies of public opinion
partly because journalists get
uncomfortable with the fact that they've
been so involved with propaganda during
World War one they and the newly
emerging journalism studies or newspaper
studies start to reflect on what's the
actual relationship between these two
things can we measure it more
statistically can we do surveys to try
to understand what people actually think
once they've read the newspaper and that
by the sort of mid 20th century starts
to emerge into public opinion surveys
things like Gallup the sorts of
techniques that we're much more used to
today what changed was there after the
initial sort of era we're talking about
in the early 20th century that maybe
didn't serve as a reset but that was
sort of the next major shift in how
public opinion and published opinion
need to be considered and evaluated
separate separately was it a
technological change that took place and
shifted us into the next phase or was it
something else in terms of the
relationships between some of these wire
services and governments or you know
something else altogether yes and one of
the things that's really important your
riot is developments of new technology
and one of the things I talk about in
this book is that we often mistakenly
see technology as something is sort of
autonomous but actually you can see with
the Germans there they become really
interested in information particularly
around 1900 and they start to see it as
a way to exert power I mean it's a bit
like they see information not a soft
power but as a way of achieving hard
power and one of the things they do at
the same time the German government for
example is to invest in a new technology
that's known as wireless telegraphy so
it's basically sending telegrams through
the air using electrical signals and the
German government subsidizes private
companies do research and development
into this new technology really driven
by this political vision that you should
be able to spread news around the world
and bypass telegraphy and submarine Kay
that many Germans fear are controlled by
the British so you can see as this
technology develops over the first few
decades of the 20th century and
accelerated by what happens during World
War one that this technology becomes
something that we call a one-to-many
technology so that means you have one
wireless tower and then it's sending to
many many wireless devices and that
wasn't how it was originally conceived
as a technology it was conceived like
telegraphy which was one cable here and
in cable there and so what you can show
is okay this technology is developing
because of political and economic
visions of what news should be and
eventually that will morph into spoken
radio as well can you talk a little bit
about how the increased restriction
within Germany in exactly the ways that
you talked about in sort of the
post-world War one era actually allowed
or or maybe even eased the way in which
the Nazi regime was able to take over
the communications within the country
yeah I mean there's there's so much
terrible irony to a lot of the this
history that I talk about because
obviously after World War one Germany
becomes a democracy but it's a pretty
febrile one there are lots of political
uprisings both on the far left and on
the far right and this is also the
moment when spoken radio emerges in the
early 1920s and one beer craft hands
plead or is charged with figuring out
how to regulate this industry and he
thinks radio is a great opportunity it's
a way that we can bring together this
population we can give people who are
tired entertainment classical music we
can uplift them through educational
programs but we need to have some state
supervision of what's going on here cuz
we don't have too much news because news
might inspire more political uprisings
and as the Vimal Republic goes on
political unrest continues there will be
multiple radio reforms pushed by people
like greed or who say okay we actually
need more state supervision over this
content because it's a way to actually
preserve democracy because we can stop
news from sowing further divisions in
the population so a couple of radio
reforms and what that means is there's
essentially state supervision of content
by the time the Nazis come to power
so that ironically these measures that
were meant to save democracy they
that when the Nazis come to power
immediately they have control of radio
content so there's this moment in August
in 1933 about seven months after the
Nazis come to power where Joseph
Goebbels the propaganda minister says
the Nazis couldn't have come to power
and held it like they did without the
airplane and the radio and the airplane
was something that made Hitler seem very
modern because he flies around and gives
lots of speeches so that helps him come
to power
but it's the radio that helps the Nazis
really secure their position and
establish an authoritarian dictatorship
it seems that there's this interesting
analogy between the use of
communications technology for
propagandizing and the possibility that
any technology can also be intercepted
or manipulated so like from the IT side
there's always this idea that every time
there's a new technology with it come
new ways of possibly interfering hacking
whatever the case may be even back to
like using drums in Africa to
communicate from one village to another
whether or not some rival village was
coming those drums signals could also be
intercepted and manipulated in the sort
of same way it seems that with every new
communication technology came ways in
which it could and was used for
propaganda purposes in some sense yeah I
think that's right and the other thing
that we can see even building on top of
that is that there are quite similar
rhetoric surround new technologies which
which even brings us up to the Internet
today so you can see with radio for
example initially there's sort of
utopian rhetoric it's gonna be the
savior of the nation that's true in
Germany in Britain in the US as well
it's going to bring people together it's
going to make a community out of these
fractured societies where
industrialization and sort of pull
people apart so initially it's really
you Toki and rhetoric about what radio
can do and then in the 1930s when
Mussolini in Italy or Hitler Germany are
using radio to try and broadcast fascist
propaganda within their countries and
also outside of it now radio seems to be
a tool of demagogues and dictators so we
see this as move from utopian hopes into
dystopian nightmares and then often
settling somewhere in between a
recognition that
ecology is neither our Savior nor is it
our devil it's what we as humans make of
it that matters most is there or are
there ways in which the sort of role and
positioning of Fox News in the United
States today have parallels or analogues
to what you talked about in the book
from the early 20th century so there
there is some analog I think so there's
there's one right-wing media magnate a
man called Alfred Hooton Berg who
creates a whole vertically integrated
media empire so he has everything from
the paper companies that are
manufacturing the paper for his
newspapers newspapers advertising
agencies his own news agency and then he
also ends up buying the biggest film
company in buy more Germany which was a
very big film industry at that point the
one that made films like Fritz Lang's
Metropolis for example and hooting both
company does bear some resemblances to
Fox in the sense that he basically asks
his editors to push what he calls a sort
of nationalist point of view something
that's more autarkic he has a particular
political party that he supports but he
doesn't want the editors to necessarily
just support that party we just have a
particular point of view and ironically
what ends up happening is the amount of
support for his right-wing party drops
but much more support is created for
Hitler so he sort of outmaneuvered in
many ways because people don't vote as
his newspapers tell them to they
actually vote further to the right and I
think there are some parallels to the
way that Fox supported certain
candidates in the primaries for the 2016
election then it ends up being Donald
Trump who actually gets the vote who's
not necessarily the candidate putting
forward the views that Fox News would
have represented at that point but that
Fox also makes its accommodations with
Trump yeah that's interesting because
I've been reminding my audience that
early in the 2016 primary Fox was
actually not behind Donald Trump and in
fact there were some pretty high profile
conflicts between Trump and Fox News at
a certain point and I don't know if it's
when Fox realized that Trump had the
momentum or what exactly pushed it over
the edge Fox did become very Pro Trump
and and sort of got to where it was over
the last couple of years but I also
believe that if the
continued polling trouble is very
visible for Donald Trump and it seems as
though he might lose in 2020 I don't
think Fox News will necessarily stick
with him I mean they are decidedly
right-wing and their funders it impose
that they must continue to push a
right-wing agenda but I don't actually
think that it's about Donald Trump
specifically and I wouldn't be surprised
to see that change
right and it's also about bottom lines I
mean it is it is a commercial profit
television right it's for profit and if
your advertisers are withdrawing their
support I think that actually brings us
right back to the beginning of our
conversation about published versus
public opinion so opinion poll are taken
as the main sort of proxy for public
opinion and if those fall below a
certain point and if Fox sees its
viewership drop and the number of
advertisers drop that could certainly
lead to different perspectives being
shown on Fox now moving away from being
right-wing I doubt it but changing some
of those perspectives I think it's it's
not impossible and you're quite right to
remind people of that 2016 moment where
Fox makes certain decisions and and
doesn't necessarily support Trump
wholeheartedly at all when you look back
at the earlier broadcast they were
pushing other candidates like Ted Cruz a
lot of what we've been discussing today
is from the book news from Germany the
competition to control world
communications 1900 to 1945 we've of
course been speaking with the book's
author dr. Heidi toric who's an
assistant professor of international
history at the University of British
Columbia Heidi's so great to talk to you
today I appreciate your time thanks so
much for having me David